keeping it reel 2 reals how we keep it
handy Saturday Daily Show bismillah al
hamdulillah greetings of peace assalamo
alaikum thank you for being with me for
a few minutes I just wanted to go ahead
and expound on some things that I think
are very important especially during
this month of Ramadan we know that
Ramadan is something that is a
continuation of the legacy and the
mission of all the prophets that the
crater sent Jesus fasted Moses fasted
Abraham fasted they were all natural
monotheists they only worship the crater
not the creation they all establish
prayer which we do five times a day they
all gave in charity which we do they all
visited Becca Becca first house of
worship built by Abraham to commemorate
the worship of the one creator and Islam
being a way of life that protects the
sanctity of life that protects your mind
and especially your heart that's what I
want to focus on you know the last final
messenger sent to man kind of Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he said there's a morsel of flesh in the
body that if its sound the whole body
will be sound we have so many toxins
from the pollution from food toxins fake
food you know I've been talking a lot
about fake food this particularly this
toxin the spiritual toxins the things
that we see the things that we hear they
affect our heart Ahriman our faith is
either going up or down if you're
listening and bobbing your head in the
car during Ramadan if you can control
yourself your nephs your desires
especially now during this training camp
during Ramadan it's going to be much
easier well law is going to be much
easier now and that's the whole goal the
mission that afterward makan Ramadan you
come out a better muslim a better
submitter to the Creator a better human
being you've developed yourself if you
lose out now what am I going to say come
on now's the time
if you're bobbing your head to Lady Gaga
googoo 55 cents Tupac Kate Perry Miley
Cyrus you name it this is affecting your
heart this is going to with this audio
pornography and all this hip hop bling
billing music you got to cut it out
replace it with with the Quran the
verbatim word of God listen in your car
in your in your car you have in your way
when you're traveling you have so many
apps out there where you can listen to
good positive messages good lectures
good reminders and you'll see that you
feel different admit I mean think about
that when you when you you know you
might have a moment of that feel good
and you're moving around and you know
going faster in the car and you like
they put you in a la la fantasy land
that's all it does that then what would
it incites these desires and you want to
you know you start thinking of things
you want to go do things and all these
things are mostly bad things like you
end up just being hit in a hypnosis
state but as much as we're aware we're
cognizant of the reality that life is a
gift and every moment is is precious
well asset in El in Santa Fe hosted in
ladina I'm a noir middle sorry Hattie
what they also bit hockey what the wall
so be sober the Creator is swearing by
time look all mankind is bankrupt this
is what we have and we're wasting it the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him the things that people take for
granted is what good health and time so
you're wasting time you're not getting
any good deeds but you're actually
having the Melek writing the bad deeds
when you're listening to things that are
actually calling you to the disobedience
and to two things that are not
appropriate and only bring harm upon
yourself that's why you you feel this
trepidation you feel this unease
confusion which this creates another
thing i want to touch upon it i'm done
is the social media these tools many of
them can be used for great good but when
we're constant
if you have so many friends people don't
you don't even know would you accept a
stranger came up to say hey can I just
be your friend you don't know this
person is person's befriending you and
now or even you have other people out
there that may be family man who ever
the case you end up how much time are we
spending looking at other people's
profiles how much time are you spending
checking on Instagram the person that
took that nice shot that picture perfect
shot and now you're judging your life
and you sing oh how happy they are and
how miserable I am you know the prophet
saw something said always look to those
who have less you appreciate what you
have and now you're looking at you don't
know if that person right after that
picture had the worst argument with
their wife their house is upside down
they took three hours just to plant that
perfect picture whatever the case don't
get caught up and then you have let's
say just for an example we have a
conservative number 50 friends right and
every day on the newsfeed you're going
through each one you're giving one
minute on top of Facebook we're not even
adding snapchat subhana imagine how much
time you're wasting and you're going to
be asked about that and if you would
have taken that time and implemented now
especially during the month of Ramadan
into the Quran there shouldn't be a day
that passes that at least you don't read
one page pick up a good English
translation if you don't even know the
Arabic and read at least one page at
least one can you commit to one one ayah
how about that but come on you could do
more one page and instead of the music
the bling-bling the filth that you see
many much of on the TV even the it's not
even the cable just the regular TV I say
cut it out because what do you see even
in the commercials promiscuity solve
pornography that all affects the heart
that you want to protect and that this
Dean came to protect and if it's not
sound the whole body will not be sought
you will be affected your mind will be
affected your clarity of thinking will
be effective it's going to go down and
no wonder the mood swings
you're going to be anxious nervous
anxiety you're going to be missing out
on that piece of contentment that
happiness we all are successful to these
toxins this is a reminder first to
myself and to those listening that we
have to be aware of this how much time
are we putting into looking at the
picture perfect moments that people are
taking and you're seeing a lot of a lot
of inappropriate pictures out there
sisters protect yourself part of being a
woman in hijab is that that modesty this
also goes for the brothers with the baby
gap t-shirts and whatnot cut this out
same thing with the sisters she's a shy
intelligent strong woman that was
respected for her mind not exploited for
her body and Muhammad Ali he gave a
great you know we we we promote oh this
modern-day American hero see what his
stance was what's what's wrong with with
miniskirts what's wrong with with with
Hall pounds number one I have a wife and
she's walk around the skirt up to here
and then what's happening well while I
won't hear better seal what's the man I
mean people looking at Rican they lusted
for all kind of freaks and no good
people on the streets while I want my
wife she came down over because the pan
is show off the wind blow shows it
behind cows but animals and mules human
beings don't walk and out savages
walking over to behinds out and my
wife's behind him and look at instance
unmake strong sense so how can I protect
my woman if I'm wrong then she she's
half-naked some saddest run up and grab
her hell I shouldn't put out there if I
got merchandise I'm gonna sell I put
them up in winter view to see so if I
want my wife why don't want any better
see my wife what's pride it was mine
everybody looking at her it was me
what's wrong with it how can you have a
wife somebody look anything God made
pressures he nature has it you cannot
find diamonds easily you have to dig and
dig and dig me gotta work to clean them
you cannot you cannot find listen you
did not find gold everything got me
valuably made a hard to get Pearl's
rubies and a midol you have to dig and
have time you don't strike every
thank God created that was valuable he
made it hard to get to a my woman more
important than some diamonds and all of
some gold when she's the fields produced
my sons and daughters why should she
walk around all nude in all of these
design clothes her breasts out she's on
the beach wearing clothes that show more
than her panties when she go to bed
that's right people own just might as
well come out with a brassiere own and
her penance she'd be more covered up
does she do in the European style with
just something coming up on her nipple
and just a little old g string over and
she's walking out on the beach naked
these are savages I'll have my have my
daughter my wife and my woman walk
referee manda look I do boy I get to
hurt Edison well I want that farce he's
mine what you mean what's wrong with the
orbit around half neck and what our Dean
how it came to preserve and protect and
now you see others and now you think
you're missing out and you think you're
going to gain some happiness by showing
more because they are because you become
desensitized the culture is promoting it
no no no you're affirm your muslimah
you're an ambassador you follow the
example of jesus' mother mary emily
sarah and you protect your chastity your
morality your modesty and you have a
great reward promised from the Creator
from allah for you for that and it's a
struggle it is a struggle it's a jihad
to struggle to be upon righteousness of
virtue while everyone around you is
calling you to do the opposite don't do
the opposite spin let's spend our time
wisely what do we take from this throw
out the cds throw out the music that
things that are enticing you that are
waking up these not helping you to
suppress the desires they're waking up
the desires and motivating you to the
disobedience is this pleasure of your
Creator Allah subhanAllah dollar and
replace it with good messages good tones
with good advice with Quran
and let's tone it down you use these
social media tools for things that are
constructive that will help to increase
the Iman if you're seeing that it's
because it goes to the eyes to the heart
it penetrates and man it's like a poison
it hurts it hurts brothers it hurts when
you look at an appropriate thing you're
not lowering against and same thing for
the sisters it hurts so we have a
mission in this life we have a purpose
in this life and is to plant these seeds
of goodness and to help make the society
a better place help make our lives that
we live an example for others to follow
of goodness not to just sir come to the
cultural norms that many go against the
values that we try to live by and the
ambassador's of this Dean I hope this
these few minutes that I spent with you
can help motivate you can help encourage
you to spend more time with the Quran to
spend more time learning our deen
because it will only benefit you in this
life and definitely every second that
you spend learning the Dean it's an
active ibadah there is no time lost when
you spend time on these other things
you're losing much time and you're
humiliating only hurt heaviness on the
scales that we don't want to fill we
want to fill the other ones the good one
on the right that the Melek is writing
that's it thank you for spending a few
minutes with me tune in every week to
the Dean show if you haven't subscribed
to our channel subscribe already until
next time ever every Friday new episode
inshallah God willing until then
assalamo alaikum peace be with you